good morning my name is a cut from I'm a
professor of archaeology at Yale and it
is my privilege to chair the first
session of this conference which will
cover current concerns on the ground and
will include presentations by local
international specialists on the
situation of cultural heritage sites in
the Middle East and in Africa that have
been affected by political turmoil in
the past years and sometimes decades our
first presentation will be about the
situation in Iraq which has in a way
provided the script for the sad events
that have since then been played out in
many countries in the Middle East and in
Africa therefore think it is really
important that we do have a presentation
on Iraq however unfortunately our
scheduled speaker Abdullah Abdullah Mia
a Hamdani was unable to obtain a visa
and so what I have to do is I have to
present its presentation today myself
this is not so easy because I received
it only this morning and has 51 slides
and we have to be quick because please
try to keep to the schedule of roughly
seven minutes I have to do the same
thing and I have to rush through this
first presentation let me briefly
introduce mr. hamdani he is at PhD
candidate at Stony Brook University who
has for many years served as a director
of the Dakar office of the Iraqi state
board of Antiquities in southern Iraq it
is really a pity that he cannot be here
and his presentation is is very
impressive sad but very impressive and
at least through this presentation we
will have an idea of what he was going
to tell us here so mr. al hamd ani arm
was going to talk about the impact of
wars and bar gross occupation and
terrorism on the Iraqi culture heritage
in the last four decades you see
some of these things that have been
going on here before the iraq-iran war
that started in nineteen eighty Iraq had
the best antiquity service in the Middle
East yeah there we go I just have to I
don't see it here on the screen some it
had control of the sites with local
inspectors some twenty five PhDs in the
Department of Antiquities that museums
throughout the country good control over
their holdings a national international
expeditions worked all over the country
Iraq was able to send archaeologic
expectations expeditions even to
excavate in places such as the Gulf
states and Yemen during the 1980s war
though missiles attacks on Baghdad began
to change the picture the iraq museum
closed its galleries research and
excavation projects were reduced to
minimum because of the war funding
the iran-iraq war ended in 1988 it was
one of these phases of hopes that were
all too often then disappointed after a
wild with the Gulf War of 1991 the
situation became much worse again and as
preparations were made to protect
antiquities from damage the object in
the museums galleries were packed out
again for safety some removed to
regional museums the most valuable were
stored in a vault in the National Bank
and again show you a couple of slides
illustrating this situation without
saying anything actually these were
things that were stored in the central
in the National Bank in Baghdad from or
nimrood these are local museums that
were regional museums that were attacked
in the aftermath of the war the first
time this actually happened ever in Iraq
and here we move on to the next phase
the phase of of the embargo that was
imposed on Iraq between 19 and 9 90 and
2003 a time when many objects on museum
stayed in storage the staff of the
abutment iniquities at least many of
them left Iraq and archaeological sites
started suffering first from organized
looting and the expansion of agriculture
diluting start among other things
because of the no-fly zones the
government was no longer able to control
the North and the South of Iraq again I
show you couple of slides related to
this that show some of the issues here
at stake
right and here we move on again towards
the war of 2003 in preparation for this
war the staff of the iraq museum moved
and of other museums in iraq move
manuscripts and objects to bank away
from the museum's large objects were
protected by films and sand bags on in
on april 9th 2003 the iraq museum was
looted and many pieces were moved to a
bunker and and thousands of objects were
stolen from the galleries and from
storages in the museum including many of
the of the most important objects some
were actually later recovered as you can
see on this slide here it was Donnie
George and number of staff members of
the iraq museum as they inventory some
of the objects that were returned to the
museum many by by local citizens here
are some additional slides showing the
return of such objects some were
actually obviously in in much worse
condition than when they had originally
been taken away yeah this slide shows
one of the worst consequences of the
2003 war the increased looting of sites
this looting had to some extent already
taking place during the 90s but no it
escalated and worse conducted on almost
industrial scale again I have to move
forward here with a couple of additions
guys like this is particularly well
depressing I should say because you see
the surface of the side of eason in
southern Iraq the lunar landscape where
nothing is actually essentially
excavator anymore
let me because I think this isn't
important for us to hear let me let me
read from your few lines that reflect
mr. al hamdulillah spur Sinell
experiences at the time of the 2003 wore
my headquarters were were in NASA we are
museum like all local the residents I
stayed home during the battle for NASA
via but when I return to work I found
that my museum had been taking over as
the headquarters from United States
Marine stationed in Nigeria this gave me
the opening to urge them to include a
geological protection within their
mission and then he recalls here and I
don't have the time to really go into
that how he collaborated with the army
and eventually managed to get sites
protected and work on getting deluding
more under control this also here is
interesting on this slide you see the
that that mr. Erhan Ghani appealed to
the Grand Ayatollah Sistani to issue a
fatwa making it plain that looting was
actually against Islamic law including
both of Islamic and pre Islamic sites
and Al sistani issued such a fat bodies
of course a measure that really can have
an effect so I think this is important
to keep this in mind and mr. [ __ ]
really deserves praise for having
initiated this fatwa
there's a long passage in the paper that
I cannot really read to you about the
reasons why the looting actually takes
place including of course poverty that
leads people to loot sides because they
have no other way of making a living mr.
alhan Downey also points out and that
might be worth briefly reading that to
you that the willingness of the people
to take up looting comes in part from
the connection that they make within the
state in Iraq deep past and here he
gives you as an example these breaks
inscribed in the name of Saddam Hussein
and built into the walls of
Nebuchadnezzar seconds palace in Babylon
just like earlier bricks of that very
Babylonian king had been built into the
rewards so this close association
between a repressive regime and the
ancient world al hamdulillah points out
in his paper may to some extent of
course have motivated some people to to
consider these antiquities as as as
problematic and not really worth of
protection yeah I have to move on
quickly here so I have to skip a lot of
these slides
and I actually moved to the to the scent
can ultimate we hope chapter of this
this story because I hope the final
chapter will again be being more
positive about Isis taking over northern
and northwestern Iraq in 2014 in jun
2014 Isis as you all know conquered the
city of Mosul and since then has been in
control of several important Iraqi
cities with a significant cultural
heritage and and some 4,000
archaeological sites and well this is
probably fairly familiar to you at this
point some of the most prominent sights
that were deliberately targeted biases
so the new quality of destruction namely
delivered to structure of cultural
heritage including nav the serving
capital of Nineveh discerning capital of
course abad nimrood where the northwest
palace of raja Bonnie I'll show notes
about the second was completely
destroyed in the explosion the Roman
city of hatke and also a number of
museums especially the Mosul museum and
then of course and that is something
obvious you should never forget numerous
shrines tombs and churches including she
I and Sonia shrines some especially in
the in the city of Mosul were where the
cultural heritage is really largely been
eradicated the most disastrous
demolition was that of the mosque of the
prophet Jonah never Eunice on the side
of Nineveh which was demolished on july
twenty fourth of 2014 and this
destruction is still ongoing I heard
yesterday that they are confirmed rumors
it seems that the master key gate one of
the great gates and the city wall of
Nineveh was bulldozed by Isis this is
what you get instead a new minaret that
well phrases then
the new so-called Calif al-baghdadi you
see a bath daddy in Arabic written on
top of this minaret there and see that
up here in the city of Mosul so let me
wrap this up I skim through this year
but let me read the last paragraph of
mr. alejandra newspaper to you which is
kind of an appeal the international
community should support Iraq and
protecting its rich and diverse cultural
heritage according to international
legislation and United Nations
agreements the international community
has to live up to its legal humanitarian
and cultural responsibilities to protect
the cultural heritage of countries and a
risk such as Iraq in these days the
Iraqi neighbor countries should not
allow the smuggling broad of the stolen
artifacts from Iraq protecting rocks
cultural heritage is a global task for
it is the culture it's part of the
cultural memory of all humans so this
was the presentation dr. Adani would
have liked to give himself here but
unfortunately wasn't able to so thank
you for your attention and um
you